la maison heffel a tenu cette semaine sa
vente aux enchères semestriels d'oeuvres
d'art et parmi les artistes qui étaient
représentés des grands noms canadien
mais aussi internationaux en passant par
col v le riopelle picasso le mieux ou
encore andy warhol et de partout sur la
planète et des centaines d'investisseurs
et amateurs d'art qui ont pris part à
distance cet événement avec comme
résultat des ventes totales de 15
millions de dollars et même plus de 15
millions de dollars
j'en discute avec tania poggio nec et la
directrice du bureau de la maison heffel
à montréal mon jour madame peau de
journée bonjour d'entrée de jeu vous
allez lui dire sa cure vaut également
aussi les montrer aux téléspectateurs
quels tableaux ont battu des records
lors de cette vente avait des très
grands noms la wii alors comme l'avait
dit ont représenté 112 donc 112 ou lors
de cette vente printanière que lieu le
15 juillet à toronto alors parmi ces
grands noms retrouver des oeuvres par
exemple le alex covivo fracassé le
record pour cet artiste une oeuvre
exceptionnelle membres de notre malaise
alors c'est john baird je croise sur le
nom de l'oeuvre
exactement comme en bleu suite bd partie
d'une collection privée durant toutes
ces années c'est la première fois que
sept avaient été présentées aux enchères
et on est lui ravi que notre employée
pour cette exceptionnelle et trouvé écho
chez les collectionneurs
alors il ya eu 5 5 par contre les
francas et donc ce mois 2,4 millions de
dollars donc un record pour cet artiste
et là ça nous surprend un petit peu
parce que beaucoup moi comme les
personnes peut-être aussi donc à toutes
nos téléspectateurs parfois pas assez
parce qu'on regardait la lys s'il y
avait aussi un picasso on se rend compte
que le tableau d' alex colville s'est
vendu plus cher que le picasso ce que
vous ça vous surprend
chicken est évalué selon le marché
c'est du cas par cas mais le trafic
était une oeuvre aussi magnifique
c'était une huile sur toile de 1939
début de la guerre et c'est une oeuvre
qui est vendu pour cru points 3 millions
dans notre vente effectivement n'avait
on avait des artistes tant état d'un
quelconque analyse sur la même stein
alors aux [ __ ] et c'est vraiment le
marché retient une autre oeuvre celle de
jean paul riopelle également qui a
trouvé probable croix avec un prix
jusqu'à en boîte je lui pique à saoula
le réveil envoi d'alertés tableau oui
magnifique vraiment de quel idéal je
pouvais toujours très bien représenté
dans vos ventes
alors on avait cette oeuvre de l'artiste
les deux breloques dont vous parlez leur
ai dit qu'ils étaient coupées leur
maîtrise de la sélection flopée une
oeuvre de 1970 vraiment de qualité
muséale qui a trouvé preneur pour 1.2
millions donc appel à des artistes
cannabinoïdes a prié les plus connus sur
le marché de l'art international
c'est donc jean paul lemieux ou des jean
paul lemieux ce que ça trouvé preneur
oui demain jean paul lemieux qui aussi
citer tous
la convoitise sur le marché qui s'était
c'est important pour nous de présenter
dans le cadre d'une même famille
d'artistes canadiens aux côtés des farc
et internationaux de renom était
important pour nous d'avoir par exemple
une option bicho aux côtés du neuf de
marque espérant que nos artistes
canadiens le 5 juin mandatement courant
l'homme ces mêmes courants
internationaux d histoire de l'art web
sont au même niveau mais à l'arrivée à
calais l'artiste québécois que j'allais
le plus d'attention à la retraite quel
peintre paul vi au ps il est temps aussi
de constater et les cris de la part d
une très belle exposition michel riou
pelle qui a circulé à québec toronto et
qui avait reculé en rampe alors où on a
vu aussi le fondateur président et qui
fait qu'ils étaient l'objet d'une très
belle exposition elle changeait la
baston et on sait qui est qui a terminé
au canada alors c'est beau de pouvoir
constater cette appréciation à
l'international nos artistes canadiens
là où vous l'avez évoqué vous avez battu
des records et ce malgré la pandémie
j'ai envie de vous poser la question est
ce que le marché de la connaît pas la
crise finalement alors faire c'est sûr
que dans les derniers mois
on ne vécut de profonds changements
socio-économiques dans le temps le
contexte de pandémie
le marché de l'art la maison et sel et
le chef de file du marché de l'art
on a su adapter notre modèle où
justement pouvoir permettre aux
collectionneurs de participer à nos
ventes et de façon de façon virtuelle à
distance soit effectivement en
augmentation l'avant du 15 juillet par
les vents il y avait trois façons pour
les avilit les collectionneurs dans ce
film à paris les deux parents paternels
partie téléphone et par ordre d'achat
pour la première fois nous avons nous
avons adapté notre modèle ou pouvoir
recevoir des enchères également en ligne
en direct alors a permis à plus d'une
centaine de collectionneurs de pouvoir
participer à distance à ses ventes que
tu t'es vraiment un grand engouement
oui en terminant comment se passe le
canada sur le marché international des
oeuvres d'art le canada se tient très
bien la maison et prier et dans
on n'essayait pas de palmarès mais son
enfant au monde
et puis le canada vers la plage c'est
con mais plutôt de pouvoir présenter des
artistes canadiens aux côtés des grands
noms internationaux
ça démontre recul important et
l'importance de leur actif également
dans 70 pays
l'engouement qu'on voit les résultats de
ces vampires qui démontre prouve à quel
point en ces périodes de profonds
changements quel point l'art contenu des
spirées l'élan continue d'importer okubo
l'heure aucun enseignement extractives
absolument et du réconfort et vous
l'avez également aussi c'est la
célébration nos artistes
je remercie énormément tania pas de
jaune et d'avoir été avec nous je vous
en prie merci à vous à plaisir